>>> THE U.S. EMBASSY SAYS THE
KABUL AIRPORT IS CLOSE D FOR
THOSE WITH SPECIAL VISAS,
IMMIGRANTS.
AFGHANS WHO WORKED ALONGSIDE
U.S. FORCES AND ALSO THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS.
I'VE OBTAINED LETTERS FROM THE
TALIBAN TO THE BROTHER OF AN
AFTERNOON BEGAN INTERPRETER WHO
WORKED WITH U.S. TROOPS AND THE
TALIBAN ACCUSES HIM OF HELPING
AMERICANS AND PROVIDING SECURITY
TO HIS BROTHER.
A FINAL LETTER -- THERE ARE
THREE LETTERS HERE.
NOTIFIES HIM OF HIS GUILT AND
THAT HE HAS BEEN SENTENCED TO
DEATH.
AND IT SAYS THIS, QUOTE, THESE
COURT DECISIONS ARE FINAL AND
YOU WILL NOT HAVE THE RIGHT TO
OBJECT.
YOU CHOSE THIS PATH FOR
YOURSELF, AND YOUR DEATH IS
IMMINENT GOD WILLING.
THE LETTERS CONTRADICT
ASSURANCES MADE BY A TALIBAN
SPOKESMAN AT A NEWS CONFERENCE
LAST WEEK THAT THEY WOULD NOT
RETALIATE AGAINST AFGHANS WHO
HELPED AMERICA AS THEY'RE TRYING
TO PROJECT A MORE MODERATE IMAGE
TO THE WORLD THAT MANY AFGHANS
AND MANY AMERICAN OBJSERVERS AS
WELL ARE VERY MUCH QUESTIONING.
AND AT LEAST SEVEN AFGHANS ARE
DEAD AFTER A FRANTIC SCENE THIS
WEEKEND SAW CROWDS OF PEOPLE
OUTSIDE THE KABUL AIRPORT
INVOLVED IN A STAMPEDE, IN A
DESPERATE RUSH TO LEAVE THE
TALIBAN-CONTROLLED COUNTRY.
ONE WOMAN, AN AFGHAN JOURNALIST
AND INTERPRETER, RECORDING THIS
CHILLING MESSAGE OF THE SCENE.
>> THEY STEPPED ON ME AND THE
BABIES.
I'M NOT GOING.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW WHERE IS MY
BABY.
FAMILY.
OH, PLEASE, I'M NOT GOING
ANYMORE.
I WOULD RATHER DIE THAN SEE MY
FAMILY DIE LIKE THIS.
>> JOINING US NOW IS LYN SECHLT
Y ADDARIO, PHOTOJOURNALIST, WHO
HAS BEEN COVERING AFGHANISTAN
FOR MORE THAN 20 YEARS.
LYNSEY, IT IS HEARTBREAKING TO
HEAR THIS VOICE MEMO.
TELL US ABOUT THIS.
TELL US ABOUT, YOU KNOW, WHAT
YOU THINK AND WHAT YOU FEEL WHEN
YOU HEAR THIS.
>> HANG ON.
I NEED A MINUTE.
THESE ARE THE MESSAGES I'M
WAKING UP TO.
I'M SORRY.
>> NO, TAKE YOUR TIME.
>> TIME IS RUNNING OUT.
I MEAN, WE'RE ASKING THESE GIRLS
TO GO DAY AFTER DAY, AND WE NEED
TO GET THEM IN THE GATES.
>> LYNSEY, TAKE YOUR TIME.
I'M TAKING A MOMENT MYSELF HERE.
YOU KNOW, LYNSEY, WE'RE HEARING
THAT SPECIAL IMMIGRANT VISA
HOLDERS OR APPLICANTS MAY NOT BE
ALLOWED IN.
I KNOW YOU'RE HEARING THAT.
THEY'RE NOT BEING ALLOWED IN
RIGHT NOW.
AND, OBVIOUSLY, YOUR CONCERN IS
THAT THEY MAY NOT BE ALLOWED IN
FROM HERE ON OUT.
>> YEAH.
THIS IS THE MESSAGE WE WOKE UP
TO TODAY, THAT THE GATES ARE
CLOSED AND NO ONE ELSE CAN GET
IN.
SO, IF YOU WERE LUCKY ENOUGH TO
GET IN BEFORE TODAY, THEN YOU
CAN GET OUT.
BUT WE HAVE PEOPLE LIKE THIS
JOURNALIST WHO HAS GONE, SHE HAS
BEEN TRAMPLED.
FOR US TO ASK HER TO GO BACK
AGAIN DAY AFTER DAY, IT TAKES A
LOT.
WE'RE ASKING THEM TO RISK THEIR
LIVES.
THEY'RE WITH THEIR CHILDREN.
THEY'RE WITH THEIR FAMILIES.
I DON'T KNOW.
I HAVE NO IDEA HOW TO DO THIS.
>> SO, WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT --
WE HEAR HER TALKING ABOUT -- SHE
HAS SEEN A CHILD INJURED.
SHE'S TALKING ABOUT NOT KNOWING
WHERE HER BABY IS.
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THAT?
>> SHE FOUND HER BABY.
SHE HAS A 2-YEAR-OLD BABY.
WE'RE STILL TRYING TO GET HER
OUT.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING SINCE 5:00
THIS MORNING WITH A GROUP OF
WOMEN AND A GROUP OF JOURNALISTS
WHO HAVE WORKED WITH VARIOUS
PUBLICATIONS, INCLUDING NATIONAL
GEOGRAPHIC.
YOU KNOW, WE'RE TRYING.
WHEN YOU HEAR THE GATES ARE
CLOSED AND EVERY DAY THEY GO,
THEY GET TRAMPLED, THERE ARE
SHOOTINGS, PEOPLE ARE GETTING
KILLED.
IT'S A LOT TO ASK FROM US
SITTING IN NEW YORK, LONDON, GO
TO THE GATE AGAIN.
BRING YOUR FAMILY.
WE'RE TRYING TO DO THIS IN THE
RIGHT WAY.
ALL SORTS OF PEOPLE WANT TO HELP
ON THE OUTSIDE.
PEOPLE WANT TO DONATE FOR
CHARTER PLANES.
THAT'S GREAT.
WE NEED YOUR HELP.
BUT WE ALSO NEED TO GET THEM
INTO THE AIRPORT.
>> SO WHEN YOU'RE HEARING --
>> I MEAN --
>> SORRY, GO ON.
>> THE TRANSLATOR WHO GOT THIS
DEATH THREAT, THIS IS THE
BEGINNING.
WE'VE BEEN WAITING FOR THIS.
IT'S NO SPICE.
IF ANYONE IS SURPRISED -- IF
ANYONE IS SURPRISED THIS IS
HAPPENING, I MEAN, THIS IS WHAT
WE'VE BEEN WAITING FOR.
>> AND SO AS WE -- LOOK, I THINK
THE QUESTION NOW IS, AND PERHAPS
CURRENTLY THIS IS WHAT THE
EMBASSY IS SAYING.
CURRENTLY THEY'RE NOT LETTING
SIVs IN.
TO BE CLEAR, THESE ARE AFTGHANS
MANY OF THEM ARE TRANSLATORS WHO
HAVE -- THEY'RE LEGALLY
ELIGIBLE, RIGHT?
THIS IS THE PROMISE THAT WAS
MADE TO THEM BY THIS COUNTRY.
>> CORRECT.
>> BUT THEY'RE NOT CURRENTLY
BEING ALLOWED IN.
DO YOU THINK THAT THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO BE CLEAR IF
THAT IS A CURRENT THING OR IF
THIS IS -- IF THAT'S THE END OF
IT?
>> LOOK, I THINK WITH EVERY DAY
THAT PASSES, THE CHANCES ARE
LESS.
SO IF YOU'RE SAYING SIV, PEOPLE
WHO RISKED THEIR LIVES FOR THE
AMERICAN GOVERNMENT, FOR THE
AMERICAN MILITARY, PEOPLE WHO
FOUGHT ALONGSIDE AFGHANS -- I
MEAN ALONGSIDE AMERICANS, TO
TELL THEM THAT THEY ARE NO
LONGER ALLOWED INTO THE AIRPORT
WHEN EVERY DAY MORE AND MORE
PEOPLE ARE GETTING THREATENED
AND KILLED OUTSIDE THAT AIRPORT
IS ASTONISHING TO ME.
>> WHAT DOES IT MEAN, LYNSEY,
FOR THOSE FOLKS TO NOT BE
RESCUED?
WHAT DOES IT MEAN FOR NOT JUST
FOR THEM, WHAT DOES IT MEAN FOR
THE AMERICAN PROCESS THAT HAS
BEEN MADE TO THEM?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, I THINK
THE AMERICAN PROMISE RIGHT NOW
IS OBVIOUSLY, YOU KNOW -- PEOPLE
ARE TAKING THAT WITH A GRAIN OF
SALT.
IT DOESN'T MAKE OUR FOREIGN
POLICY LOOK VERY GOOD IF WE
EVACUATE OUR OWN EMBASSY.
OUR FOCUS SHOULD BE GETTING MORE
PEOPLE OUT NOT TELLING SIV
HOLDERS.
YOU WILL DIE, BE EXECUTED OR
YOUR LIFE IS PRETTY MUCH OVER,
SITTING BEHIND CLOSED DOORS,
LIVING IN FEAR.
AND I THINK, YOU KNOW, THAT
LETTER THAT THAT TRANSLATOR GOT
IS THE FIRST OF MANY.
AND I THINK IT'S NOT THE 31st OF
AUGUST.
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY THE CUTOFF
TIME.
BUT I THINK AFTER THE 31st OF
AUGUST, ALL BETS ARE OFF.
AND WE HAVE NO ONE ON THE GROUND
AND WE HAVE NO LEVERAGE.
SO I'M NOT SURE WHAT WE'RE WAIT
ING FOR.
>> LYNSEY, I KNOW YOU'RE NOT
WAITING.
I KNOW YOU'RE WORKING VERY HARD
AROUND THE CLOCK TO AFFECT SOME
CHANGE HERE.
WE'LL KEEP -- I KNOW IT'S TOUGH.
I SEE IT ON YOUR FACE.
I KNOW THERE'S A HELPLESSNESS
THAT SO MANY PEOPLE WHO ARE
DOING THIS FEEL, BUT AT THE SAME
TIME THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT